I don't know how to sync it up from this
screen oh I guess I could just okay wait
yeah let me go it's good if your Mouse's
at school oh it's not so let's do this
I'm a kid yeah breaker you're a freak er
first care the time on screen Oh
one count down timer like I don't know
how to say this awesome thing is you
thinking you've ever had to do with all
of the disdain in your heart one I got
it okay you know what I'm doing I'm
editing this one at school
oh yeah should I explain the gate did
any of you explain the game to the
people watching um
at all all right this is Orcs Must Die
it's a new MOBA slash survival game
slash stuff where you play with your
friends and try to kill the enemy dead
alright so my role is pillager I'm not
talking to you [ __ ] I'm talking to
them
my role is pillager I go get steal
supplies and kill people in the back and
then he's the coward hey is the one that
doesn't help us with anything and we'll
have a very low score at the end of the
game but all of these category the best
score at the end of the game and you
just wish for cuz he just avoids
everything shut up no I don't just cuz
I'm running away currently right now
doesn't mean that I avoid everything it
sounds like what that means no when you
play a character who turns invisible and
doesn't want to get into the battle you
don't know me you let me be and I'll do
my thing and you do your thing which is
hopefully nice suck I'm slapping a door
with magic what uh magic I'm majesty Oh
oh gosh it's of the underworld if you
catch magic missle into the darkness
I'm your mobile guy I kid oh god robot
Wow
oh god gabriella deals no damage no mine
ha ha I kill Hey Wow
Oh get out of here let's take down this
Guardian right now jack oh god oh yeah
get him kill hey lock it oh let's not do
that this jungles from Eric's Chuck yeah
ah stupid thanks for all your help Marc
usually I'm I am helping you guys aren't
happy with MOBOT you're letting me get
him I guess thank you in a way there we
go got him got everything dan you're
Lizzie but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
help you I'm gonna help myself
uh-uh she blooms go they've got a love
of - portal already shut us it's fine
how could be what about that wait stop
freaking out the backlight it's just
like guys we're gonna lose we'd be
fighting oh they'll take it and stolen
whisper sunk my own health for mana
I said that's an interesting way to
describe that but okay so Jax all my
life in the corner over there while
we're trying to make the victory here I
want to look like them there's two of
them is over there deaq I know oh god I
hurt all about I thought Lance ba ya ya
never leave Wade has a [ __ ] faut
arch-nemesis yeah he's that much of a
loser you don't have any arch nemesis
it's literally not their main focus yeah
I have their main focus
hey don't you Lizzie bot haha you stole
the kill assist game roll it
take the kill a [ __ ] I'm a pillager I'm
a kitty cat pillager don't match hey
Marcus actually open the second gate I
guess I'll go put some things in it yeah
duh I'm like super cool I'm like the
best DX but you look down yet you got
you got them
winds ridiculous oh I need 1250 I only
have nine fights ow ow rub a guardian
shut your people brush shut it all off
this is my village this my shut up it's
not gonna be very interesting
thank you I'm gonna Bob oh shut the okay
wait Brogan meet Croghan me go get it
what's oh oh yeah the side Kamel
tomorrow get it I'll come help you oh
yeah enemies a tarp it'll the pole yeah
well you're all going for every team
member is going for right now team fight
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna be right
there sighs I break this box I'll be
right there
oh why are you all here get out of my
house
I literally totally failed nobody mark
wanna help
oh that's all they're out of um yeah
yeah hi this is gonna kill me it's gonna
kill me I'm gonna die I'm dead I'm
running away ha ha I can't run ha ha I
got you I got you
thank you
I think psychic we only got damn Oh No
I didn't see him die Jesus I know he got
to put them traps of the oil lady Moscow
die busy crap crap
no he's gonna run away like a beyotch oh
she's impressed how dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm so dead how about I
got that kill it was just again I need
to be better man hey I got one yeah okay
we need to go get that croaking meat now
cuz they all Lancelot ran away like a
little [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna go back to
the attack lane you guys get the meat
all right we're going to it but can I
steal this kill two right here oh god
I'm dead damn so did Mark Marcone die
no not you don't know that means like
you're gonna die
nah I got I was shot here Wow come on
come on
so close haha I got him Hey Wow
to me do you have enough coin for your
glyph yet Jack yes we should do that I
got no help but I'm trying to help you
Jack cuz I'm a friend I'm a good friend
oh god yeah another kill for me cut damn
dude I'm doing good this right Oh God
even though I'm very very very close to
death I'm gonna be killed by an old how
bad is that that's not good
we need Crowell to beat I couldn't get
it I was about to die I'm going back to
recovery III died trying to get it
they're looking for you guys over there
how hard is this I'm done got to half
what showed up and started opening
anuses
he was just like in sight that V I love
you oh well that says sound really bad
it doesn't sound that bad actually he's
kind of nice about it so like you know I
glitches down and awesome what's coming
out I will take this sling you take that
line I'm helping look I'm helping okay
thank you Mark a job thanks man
go kill [ __ ] okay I'm gonna head for
the Kroger yeah I'm gonna help - I just
I just ran IV out of there so hopefully
I'm gonna be able to Bob hi how's it
going hey whoa oh oh stop it
it's gonna suffer by mice after guys
help I'm coming
slow beef am about to break use gate so
leave me alone
yep so what the crude meat does and once
again I'm not talking to [ __ ] what
the Krogan meat does is it allows you to
get a boss I kill them Wow get the meat
put on my other [ __ ] clothes
okay so frustrating when someone takes
the spoils of what you've been working
on for so long hey I earned all those
kills just cuz you guys were so bad you
couldn't even keep up with me doesn't
mean that you need to complain about
what I'm doing shut up
we're doing meat go put a bossy no yeah
I don't wanna
whoa-oh frightened promising promising
where you go damn and I almost got dusty
but Jack don't go in there
target's death yeah take a potshot your
last what all right man
[ __ ] manor with two ever okay oh nice
you'll assist it might as well not have
hi kill this time just cuz you go tell
him nice kill that just encourages him
Oh
think I'm about to go on MOBOT come on
come here you [ __ ]
nope don't don't target me guardian you
don't need to do that ah kill sis is
[ __ ] I'm like wait everything hide
you're out you now to do it on purpose
cuz you got ranged the subscribe hey you
take them out close I'll take them out
fire all work together and we'll have a
Merry Christmas
I don't it's not even close to Christmas
but ok shut up Lance pond hurts let's
take down this Garrity n-no take that
what I'm thinking a lot of mana go here
did anyone summon a boss or did we
totally forget about that oh yeah we
totally forgot about that yeah knowing
some of the boss how I will go back
about the boss head for the next one
yeah I'm I'm attacking the Krogan right
now no one better steal my meat no one
by the name of Jack better tried to Jack
my meat mark I want your meat no Jack
not again I'm tired watch that's gotta
be a lot like someone else huh oh we
didn't actually get a boss guys yeah I
heard some one person just said that why
did you ask if some would put the boss
in if there was no bond then I answered
my own question it was a returning and
was I realize for being up here well
that's not great
ah now hit the meat
see goddamn it was my me I hope you die
I hope you die I'm gonna hook the blood
I'm not gonna help you yeah I'm ready
yeah by me I'm gonna go take it oh you
don't have any health either shut up
love it it's enough to get it in yeah
I'm marking it in he did it
oh [ __ ] okay I'm just about to respawn I
put a boss in okay no I want the credit
I want everything oh you oh you didn't
put it in wipe you give nothing you're
gonna like it
well you put that on my diet so it was
responsibility take responsibility for
your meat face the boss
Oh defender guardian of the world Oh
name work everybody here just got it
earth defender so weird and stupid yeah
man if only our jungler was gathering we
could have level 3 million portals
gathering and killing but also gathering
gathering meat does not count
I hold Oh Judy that must be why we have
level 3 minion portals hang on I got it
I'm on it
mark you laid slots in the middle he's
almost dead ok gether missed him
I totally wish I got him dodo no the
other thing
he literally hit a sweet spin kick in
midair and totally missed and go die
MOBOT you going to I [ __ ] come
on
[ __ ] gate I'm gonna push fast to get
that [ __ ] always gone ran away
little [ __ ] Oh God the couple just flew
past my head I'm attacking the Scarecrow
dammit dammit dammit that's natural
thing is annoying how all and spot just
jack slapped me
oh my god oh I got Lizzy bottom out of
here baby ha ha you do not belong here
look at MOBOT over there taking potshots
let er go away mom I in a [ __ ]
what a dick hey wait which which Lane is
doing better which lane is right now
we've got the boss in the wrong lane ok
right
come on come on come on aah
he was like three hits away oh well okay
we're about to get we're about to get
through the gate whatever man yeah
whatever man Jesus Oh [ __ ] whatever
Oh [ __ ] Oh both level three oh god no
it's fine we're almost there - dorri
you're pillager is here doing real good
work we all number three I'm about to
die
my real good work is about to be ended
I'm not I'm not I want to keep pushing
with the Guardian or the earth guy
Jackie you're getting in and out we
can't hear you
oh praise of things what I got I think
he said go upgrade the thing I think
that I think that's what he's do I don't
know like something Jack's with today
all right I got it I got the perfect
wave cuz I got the heel and hop gobbles
behind him that that sound guardian
doing I don't know he's just sort of
standing there being a dick the earth
boss is kind of glitchy once he breaks
into pieces I don't think the AI works
quite right no you think he sort of just
staying in there hey can we're gonna get
dirty though baby we're almost out of
bosses to keep his attention oh god mo
BOTS coming in we're going I've no mana
suck your life or whatever yeah that
makes me very vulnerable ha ha ha
jack is very relatable when he's sucking
himself I mean first Guardian do your
thing raise your hand if you're
surprised no wonder you don't know if I
raise my hand yeah you know I've watched
raise your hand
Bob I know you Wow where did you come
for a lot you are not running away this
tiny piece of [ __ ] I got your help yeah
I got your back there wait finish him
off but I'm gonna steal the kill don't
steal my kill but help
damn it kill my kill Oh oh god I'm gonna
dull oh I'm gonna die too
I have a heart [ __ ] I say I open this
game [ __ ] oh god dude around that you
know whatever they're stupid
come on me let's score some hounds wait
at least I made it out alive that's what
really uh that's the important thing
yeah I guess how are our secrets
oh they they got a lot of people each
other but we're about to be big score
somebody put shamans in this map in this
video that's cool I play healy shamans
cool thank you Bob that means so much
everyone's really nice they're almost
all dead but they look cool oh but
they're healy shamans but they died to
just the traps basically shish shish
there he homines jack we got a dusty Bob
behind us over here it's your counter
Oziel sure but you're likely odds aren't
your favor god I finally got land spot
the do shil hey big score big score
whoa about to win holy a big score no
you're not going anywhere [ __ ]
I'm gonna kill you hey you're not or I'm
gonna get a kill assist thanks jack
Robbie
I think we're gonna win on this next
wave if it goes like the last one did
yeah probably
how probably cuz I don't really add a
punch quick enough please rod minions
come here where the croco boot croco
there's a croco whoo-hoo no oh come on
I literally blocked her arrows with my
body so I can take the kill you have
eleven kills you [ __ ] kill stealing
baby
I'm a pillager isn't this my job I put
off two traps I was helping I was
helping I was really helping guys Jack
and I won the game so damn easy back
I kept them from winning the games ha ha
ha
alright well games over like 30 seconds
nice we did it I did it all by myself
especially at work oh definitely did it
all by yourself
yay yay yay yeah right yeah yeah yeah go
around go
yeah it's games ludicrously fun and also
to save time check out Bob Wade and
Jack's channel we all played a separate
round over on their channels I'll just
say that now so thanks guys for guiding
me to victory [ __ ] you
oh you're welcome they could play for
free [ __ ] you you're welcome
yeah go to Orcs Must Die , you can find
again I earned a thousand dong ki fat
right it's like what you already had for
brains your sunflowers the best player
back crack's for a correct ray cuz I did
was the Pope to do the lime now also I
got eight kill assist eight kill assist
but I got 12 kills yeah put the fight
kill assist for me and the eight from
Bob for oh man
wave you died three
times you bad I would have been so much
better a smaller look at the smaller
person o 1 and O smolders know how to
play or he/she does not know how to play
smolder like I did get highest damage
dealt to minions yeah cuz there that's
the best because they did it with their
yeah okay all right I will see you guys
later I'll see you in the next video bye
bye to play
yeah